bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui va vous démontrer que
tout est à vendre
même le plus grotesque il suffit de
trouver un acheteur
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des mft bonjour estelle bonjour
olivier bonjour à tous bienvenue dans
ces caches c'est le nouveau phénomène à
la mode dans le monde du numérique les
nft undji bolton en anglais jetons non
fongible en français alors que se
cache-t-il derrière ces trois lettres à
quoi servent concrètement elle et nfc et
quels sont les enjeux de cette
technologie
ce sont elles les questions qui vont
nous occuper à dans cette émission et
pour cela en deuxième partie nous serons
avec cas clair balva directrice bloc
chain et crypto chez kpmg
mais avant de rentrer dans les détails
on va vous expliquer le phénomène des
nft toutes les explications dans le
tiroir cash d'antoine d'assas c'est un
nouveau marché qui fait beaucoup parler
ces derniers mois les nft pour nos
fusils ball token jetons non fongible en
français c'est en quelque sorte la
signature numérique d'un objet virtuel
permettant ainsi de garantir son
authenticité et sa traçabilité de
manière incontestable
grâce à la bloque chain cette
technologie de stockage et de
transmission d'information transparente
sécurisé et qui fonctionne sans organe
central de contrôle
souvent associé aux cryptes aux actifs
bitcoin étaient roms et autres
techniquement un nst peut servir de
certificats pour tout et n'importe quoi
un tableau célèbre une paire de sneakers
officiel mais là où les nft prennent
tout leur sens c'est pour les actifs
numériques et autres oeuvres d'art
numérique dernièrement on a eu quelques
exemples jack dorsey qui vend le premier
tweet de l'histoire à 2,5 millions de
dollars le gif que vous avez forcément
vu du nyan cat 500 mille dollars tout de
même où la vieille vidéo virale charlie
m'a mordu qui a dépassé il 760 1000
dollars mais comment faire pour faire
valoir ses droits d'exploitation sur un
gifle ou une vidéo virale copier à de
multiples reprises
et multi diffusé que l'on peut trouver à
peu près partout sur internet
et bien c'est pratiquement impossible
posséder nft en fait c'est un peu comme
possédé une oeuvre d'art c'est parier
sur le fait qu'elle pourrait prendre de
la valeur dans les années à venir pour
éventuellement la revendre plus cher à
terme sur un modèle plus proche encore
dollars une oeuvre numérique réalisée en
plusieurs années à d'ailleurs été vendu
près de 70 millions de dollars chez
christie's un nouveau marché donc les
nft révolutionnaire ou pas on vous
laissera juge sans doute plus volatiles
qu'à un marché de l'art classique
fin mai il avait subi une chute de ses
ventes de 90%
[Applaudissements]
olivier est-il révolutionnaire selon
vous ce nouveau marché
écoutez je fais je vais très décevant
pour notre invité après face et on vend
du vide parce qu'on a beaucoup de sous à
placer et et ça permet comme pas mal de
choses en art contemporain c'est du
passé moi l'expression mais c'est du
foutage de gueule si vous voulez donc
voilà c'est un plus c'est quelque chose
qui il faut trouver un acheteur et à
partir de ce moment là vous pouvez tout
vendre c'est ce que je disais dans le
l'introduction de cette émission vous
pouvez absolument tout vendre à partir
du moment où vous trouvez quelqu'un qui
est prêt à payer pour le pur pour
l'avoir donc vous pouvez en effet vendre
des tweets plusieurs millions de dollars
ça sert à quoi c'est en quoi cet
intéressant surtout qu'en général on
sent que 140 signes vous n'aviez pas
grand chose pour vous exprimer donc vous
disiez pas toujours des choses
intelligentes donc ça n'a absolument
aucun intérêt mais je peux comprendre
qu'on en fasse un marché de toute façon
on faire marcher tout donc ça ou autre
chose
c'est pas c'est pas important bon c'est
dit merci olivier pèse tout de suite à
la deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec claire balva directrice blood chain
et crypto chez kpmg
bonjour avec les rebelles va merci à
vous d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
bienvenue dans ces caches
merci bonjour à vous peut-être peut-être
car bella pour commencer une réaction à
ce que a dit olivier en première partie
est ce que vous vous considérez ce
marché comme révolutionnaire alors je
suis à moitié d'accord en fait avec ce
que disait olivier en première partie
je suis d'accord sur le fait qu'il ya eu
ou qu'il ya encore une hype sur les nft
je suis d'accord aussi avec le fait
qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent à placer et
que la liquidité sur les marchés à
favoriser les investissements
par contre je suis pas d'accord avec le
fait que finalement ce serait se serait
que du vide parce que pour moi c'est un
outil qui est révolutionnaire et qui
changent profondément la manière dont on
gère la valeur numérique
justement on va faire un petit peu de
contexte
d'où viennent concrètement les nfc et
quand ont-ils fait leur apparition alors
ça fait quelques années que les nfc
existe mais c'est vrai que c'était
encore un outil très confidentiel
jusqu'à récemment ce qui les a
popularisé c'est à mon sens à la fois le
fait que certaines maisons d'enchères
très connus comme christie's ou
sotheby's et utiliser ces outils
donc forcément ça les a médiatisé et
puis en parallèle le fait que certaines
plateformes aujourd'hui rassemble un
grand nombre de nft différents et donc
ça va permettre d'avoir une expérience
utilisateur beaucoup plus fluide
beaucoup plus simple et donc de vendre
plus facilement sur nf t et d'en acheter
aussi plus facilement et comment est-ce
qu'on fabrique
concrètement les nft alors concrètement
c du code informatique ce sont des
lignes de codes qu'on va déployer dans
une blocs chaîne alors la plupart
d'entre eux sont sur la blogo chaîne et
terium met donc ce sont des lignes de
codes qui vont fabriquer un jeton sur
ces blocs scène olivier peut-être ce que
vous avez une question à poser avec les
rebelles va à quoi ça sert à part à part
si vous voulez a créé un nouveau marché
ça je veux bien l'entendre
comprendre que ça puisse intéresser des
gens qui au passage vont faire beaucoup
d'argent avec mais sinon à quoi ça sert
concrètement vous vous connaissez les
crypto monnaie je pense que vous avez
vues dans un débat précédemment sur les
crypto c'est un peu la même chose
c'est-à-dire que les crypto monnaie ça
va permettre de gérer de la valeur sur
internet de pair à pair donc sans
intermédiaire on va pouvoir stocker et
s'échanger de la valeur sans avoir
besoin d'une banque d'une banque
centrale bien les nftc un peu comme
décrypte monnaie à la différence que
finalement quand vous achetez un big
game 1 bitcoin c'est la même chose qu'un
autre bitcoin alors qu'un nf ce n est
pas la même chose qu'un autre nft donc
il ya une unicité et finalement avec les
nft vous pouvez créer par exemple des
collections numériques
c'est ce que fait la start-up soraire
qui vend des cartes de joueurs de
football numérique vous savez un peu
comme les cartes pokémon mais uniquement
en format numérique et donc on arrive à
numériser des choses qui auparavant
n'étaient collectionnables que sous
format physique ça me dit pas à quoi ça
sert mais qui est un marché je veux bien
comprendre qu'on puisse en en levant de
l'acheter et ces dames mais à quoi ça
sert concrètement
concrètement à rien si vous me dites que
c'est pour numériser des cartes de
joueurs
si vous voulez ça va pas me me faire
croire que ça représente quelque chose
de sérieux et d'intéressants alors
kerbala est ce qu'on pourrait considérer
cela comme un investissement
tout simplement alors ça ça peut être un
investissement effectivement ça ça peut
être une première utilité comme vous
achetez vous achetez aussi une oeuvre
d'art dans une logique d'investissement
mais c'est bien plus que ça parce que
derrière sont des outils qui sont
programmables et donc on pourrait très
bien décider si je reprends l'exemple
des cartes de jour de foot mais ça peut
être n'importe quoi d'autre on peut très
bien décider que ces cartes vous
donnerai
un accès je ne sais pas à certains
événements à certaines réductions tout
le caractère programmable de ces outils
démultiplier leur champ d'application
olivier non mais j'entends mais je vous
dis pour l'instant je ne vois pas le
l'intérêt de la chose
si vous voulez on vivait avant les nft
je pense qu'on vivra après les nefs t et
pour moi si vous voulez je pense que
dans dans quelques années on n'en
parlera plus alors maintenant il ya un
effet de mode il ya aussi ce que je
disais au départ beaucoup d'argent et
que quand il ya beaucoup d'argent on
cherche des idées pour essayer d'en
faire un petit peu plus et donc on est
tombé là dessus c'est une chose parmi
d'autres je pense qu'on n'en parlera
plus dans quelques temps mais olivier
pourquoi justement pourquoi le sac on
sait pardon et les éclairs belda non
mais alors je suis d'accord on vivait
très bien avant l'hymne ftq on vivait
aussi très bien avant avant les
smartphones on vivait très bien avant la
télé on vivait très bien avant plein de
choses ça veut pas dire que le message
ou c'est celui-là que qui n'est pas
évidente vous l'accorderait sur les nefs
t'es qui mais je pense que si vous
demande aussi vous demander à nos à nos
grands parents qui y vont pour la
plupart d'entre eux ne sont plus là
quelle est l'utilité d'un smartphone il
était aussi très sceptique finalement à
l'époque est effectivement aujourd'hui
on peut être sceptique parce que ce sont
des outils qui sont en émergence qui ont
pas encore prouvé tout ce qui pouvait
tout ce qu'il pouvait faire
mais c'est vraiment technologiquement
extrêmement intéressant parce que ça
permet de créer de la rareté numérique
alors que sur internet ça n'était pas
possible auparavant
et donc ça amène beaucoup de liquidités
effectivement et quand je dis liquidités
c'est dans le sens on peut s'échanger
beaucoup plus facilement à des outils
numériques qu'avant
olivier est ce qu ont justement est ce
qu on pourrait vous parler de vie tout à
l'heure et ce qu'on pourrait pas juste
injuste simplement considérer ça comme
un investissement différents certes de
ce qui existe aujourd'hui mais tout de
même un investissement
si vous voulez investir dans rien moi je
ne je ne vous en empêche pas stèle mais
tout peut être un investissement
vous vous dit vous pouvez tout vendre
j'ai pas si vous avez vu il ya quelques
il ya quelques semaines un artiste
italien qui a vendu pour 12000 euros
rien c'est à dire une oeuvre invisible
donc c'est bien foutu du monde il ya il
a trouvé quelqu'un pour acheter ce rien
qui n'existe pas d'accord et donc c'est
un investissement aussi parce que il
suffit que la personne en question qu'il
a acheté douze mille euros arrive à la
refiler à 15000 à un autre bongo qui
sera là pour l'acheter et tout se
passera bien et c'est un investissement
donc quand même un tableau vert de tout
un investissement
c'est comme acheter par exemple un
tableau
ah oui sauf que l'ess avait aussi acheté
un tableau blanc avec avec une toile
blanche
et si vous avez la bonne signature en
bas ça vaut quelques millions sauf que
c'est toujours rien mais à part ça vous
pouvez tout vendre c'est ce mardi au dm
depuis le départ si vous trouvez un
acheteur vous pouvez par définition tout
vent à les éclaire bel 20 mai alors pour
moi c'est une problématique assez
distinctes en fait d'aider ft1 le nfc
c'est juste un nouveau support
technologique c'est pas l'oeuvre en
elle-même donc effectivement vous pouvez
faire un effet sur rien tout comme vous
pouvez faire un nst sur quelque chose
d'extrêmement intéressant je dis pas que
tous les haines et fne sont forcément de
bons investissements
et je pense qu'effectivement certains
vont voir leur valeur largement diminuer
dans les mois ou les années à venir
mais encore une fois la vraie question
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et sur
quoi est ce qu'on crée cnft
effectivement si je crée un effet autour
de ce pas ma tasse de café ça n'a
absolument aucun intérêt
mais à l'inversé certains élèves t on
une vraie valeur sur le marché ça peut
être une valeur symbolique par exemple
ou une valeur monétaire parce qu'elle
vous confère des droits derrière et pour
bien comprendre quand on les différences
concrète entre les crypto monnaie à
classique et les analystes et à l'or
s'est effectivement les deux sont
construits sur des blocs chaîne donc
c'est assez interopérable c'est-à-dire
sur un portefeuille crypto vous pouvez
très bien détenir de l'éther qui est une
crypto monnaie et en même temps un et
next et tout ça sur le même portefeuille
mais c'est pas exactement la même chose
sens où les crypto monnaie déjà souvent
ont leur propre blog chaîne et ensuite
un nft même par rapport à d'autres
jetons à cette différence qu'il est
unique qui a pas il n'y a pas de haine
éviter qu'ils sont exactement les mêmes
en tout cas c'est pas du tout l'objectif
du nfc le but du 1 éviter c'est de ne
pas être divisible et d'avoir cette
unicité avec les rebelles va olivier on
va marquer une courte pause et on vient
dans un instant bienvenue dans ses cages
si vous nous rejoignez au sommaire cette
semaine les nft et pour cela nous sommes
en liaison avec l'acquis claire balva
directrice bloc chaîne et crypto chez
kpmg
alors on va olive est clair on va jeter
un oeil aux marchés des nfc et on va
regarder de plus près ces chiffres le 3
mai 2021 la valeur du marché
dnf t atteignez les 100 millions de
dollars pour cette seule journée
12000 c'était le nombre de portefeuilles
de nft fin mai seuls 19 4 millions de
dollars devant de nfc ont été traités en
une semaine et il ne restait plus que
3900 portefeuille comment est-ce que
l'on peut expliquer cette baisse car
balma alors il ya plusieurs explications
possibles
la première elle part il va plaire à
olivier je pense c'est que effectivement
il ya eu un effet de mode sur les nfc
qui sait peut-être un peu tassé tout
simplement comme comme tout hype qui à
un moment donné fini par se calmer pour
ensuite laisser place à de la maturité
et puis la deuxième explication c'est
une explication qui est aussi liée au
marché des crypto monnaie en général qui
a connu une hausse assez spectaculaire à
un moment et puis qui qui a légèrement
ou significativement baissé dans les
dernières semaines et qui est à un
niveau aujourd'hui un peu moindre que ce
qu'il était il ya un ou deux mois oui
mais qu'est ce que ça représente en
valeur 100 millions de dollars par
rapport au reste rien enfin 100 millions
de dollars sait rien aujourd'hui c'est
ces quantités totalement négligeable
donc c'est un début c'est après vous
qualifier le début si vous voulez mais
mes 100 millions de dollars aujourd'hui
c'est rien c'est absolument inexistant
donc c'est le sait
un minuscule volume c'est un micro micro
micro micro marché donc par rapport ne
serait-ce qu aux autres enfin aux
cryptes aux monnaies c'est ridicule par
rapport à des marchés de nous on
investit des marchés actions des marchés
c'est ridicule c'est c c'est totalement
inexistant et puis par rapport même à
une vente classique chez sotheby's où
christie's dehors en une semaine ils
vous vendent 10 fois ça donc face et
c'est juste c'est juste tout petit petit
petit marché c'est comme les cryptes
regrets alors c'est comme les cryptes
monnaie lorsqu'elles sont apparus
c'était petit aussi non alors bien sûr
en fait c'est un tout petit marché
effectivement comme olivier le dit il
faut bien voir que c'est un marché qui
n'existait pas encore il ya deux ou
trois ans donc finalement on pourra
marcher qui n'est parti rien c'est déjà
pas si mal et après alors sur la
comparaison avec ce que vendre des
maisons comme christie's ou sotheby's
alors je suis d'accord les montants sont
beaucoup plus faibles sur le marché des
f t néanmoins ce qu'on constate c'est
que le prix moyen des ventes de nft par
rapport à ce que vantent des grandes
maisons d'enchères
il est beaucoup plus faible puisque
l'objectif c'est aussi de démocratiser
un peu l'art est de permettre à des
artistes qui sont pas forcément connus
de vendre leurs oeuvres plus plus
facilement donc on est effectivement sur
des oeuvres qui sont plutôt autour de
100 200 300 euros peut-être 1000 euros
et pas sur des volumes de plusieurs
millions d'euros pour une oeuvre à
chaque fois les nefs s'adresse-t-il à
tout le monde parce que quand on regarde
les exemples de vente
on a par exemple logique nyan cat de
crise torres vendu à 580 à 1000 $ le
premier tweet de jack dorsey 2,9
millions de dollars enfin l'oeuvre de
bittle vendus à 69 3 millions de dollars
ce sont clairement des produits
numériques qui s'adresse aux plus fort
tourné aux plus fortunés
est ce que un jour les nfc peuvent
pourraient faire partie de notre
quotidien du quotidien de tout le monde
oui pourquoi pas alors effectivement là
aujourd'hui ça s'adresse plutôt à une
population qui est familier
avec le numérique est alors pour
certaines oeuvres c'est forcément une
population fortunée pour d'autres vous
n'avez pas forcément besoin d'être
fortuné pour acheter un élève t à 100 ou
200 euros
donc ça s'adresse déjà à tout le monde
maintenant est ce que tout le monde doit
acheter un et next et non je pense pas
ça dépend de votre appétence à l'art
numérique ça dépend de votre appétence
au monde du numérique en général ça
dépend aussi peut-être si vous soutenez
tel ou tel artiste qui vend cnft donc
aujourd'hui ça fait pas partie du
quotidien et je pense que c'est un outil
qui va effectivement mûrir et se
populariser à l'avenir mais ce qu'on
peut imaginer qu'il soit un jour relié à
des objets à des objets là je pense à
nike par exemple qui acquit le
connecteur et nesta une paire de baskets
on peut imaginer ça à l'avenir on peut
on peut tout à fait imaginer ça alors
tout n'a pas vocation à être un élève
temps pour autant que je le disais tout
à l'heure je vais pas faire un évité
avec matti cuillère ou ma tasse de café
mais effectivement pour des objets qui
ont une grande valeur qui peuvent être
des objets d'art et on sait bien que
dans le textile ou dans le luxe en
général
les objets peuvent vite être aussi des
objets d'art ça peut tout à fait avoir
du sens et ce caractère programmables
finalement en plus du certificat
d'authenticité permettrait par exemple
je sais pas avec votre paire de nike
d'avoir accès à certains pouvoirs
magiques dans un jeu vidéo on peut aller
assez loin dans la prospective
donc il ya un avenir d'ailleurs y at il
derrière les adapter à complètement
olivier derniers mois bah écoutez moi je
vais m'acheter la sphère de nike et je
jouerai pas dans un jeu vidéo avec des
super pouvoirs
[Rires]
mais lfp pourrait impacter par exemple
l'économie réelle selon vous à olivier
non non je vous dis pour moi c'est juste
c'est juste le produit exemple pardon
s'il marche et grossier par exemple s'il
marchait grossit grossit rapt est au fur
et à mesure de la de la bulle qui a
aujourd'hui parce qu'on déverse des
milliards tous les jours et qu'il faut
que ces milliards à quelque part donc
vous allez avoir et je pense que vous
aurez autre chose qui va sortir derrière
les nft parce qu'il faut à tout prix
trouver quelque chose pour les placer et
donc vous trouverez plein de raisons et
plein de nouveaux produits et plein de
nouvelles technologies pour vendre
quelque chose et trouver un acheteur
pour l'acheter et à quel que soit le
prix là quand vous pensez qu'on a payé
deux millions et demi pour pour un tweet
c'est quel intérêt aucun franchement
aucun donc je vous dis si vous voulez
vous payer une paire de nike à aller
acheter une paire de nike ça ira
beaucoup mieux et vous pourrez au moins
l'utiliser et la mettre au pied et ça
sera beaucoup plus intéressant que de
l'acheter virtuellement donc voila mais
bon ça c'est mon opinion après je vous
laisse vous faire la vôtre là dessus
avec leur valve avant de se quitter
juste une dernière question on l'a vu le
marché a chuté de 90% est ce que ça
pourrait rebondir encore fortement
l'avenir
alors ça
ça va dépendre à mon avis de
l'éventuelle hausse ou l'éventuelle
baisse qui peut y avoir sur les marchés
des crypto en général ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le prix aujourd'hui de
cnft souvent peut être libellés en et
terre ou dans certaines crypto donc en
fonction du cours des crypto on peut
avoir une fluctuation en euros assez
nette du marché des nfd donc ça peut
tout à fait rond dire ça peut continuer
sa baisse et c'est très difficile de
prévoir sa merci beaucoup à clerval va
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes directrice blog
shane et crypto chez kpmg
olivier nous on continue avec les
questions cash est une question de
georges cette semaine comment trouver le
bon équilibre entre attractivité et
contrôles trop de contrôles pourrait
effrayer les investisseurs étrangers
olivier wyssa pourrait effrayer les
investisseurs étrangers mais ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que toutes les tous
les pays se se gardent de de vendre tous
leurs actifs et surtout les actifs
stratégiques sauf la france qui a
l'habitude de vendre ses actifs
stratégiques à l'étranger mais mais il
faut se protéger parce qu'on peut pas
non plus laisser les étrangers faire
n'importe quoi chez nous et qui est même
pas de réciprocité très souvent c'est à
dire que on ouvre les frontières pour
les investisseurs étrangers parce qu'on
n'a pas de soucis c'est ça quand on a
pas quand on n'a pas la possibilité
justement de garder les entreprises chez
nous et ben on les laisse partir parce
qu'on n'a pas les moyens de faire
autrement
hélas
et à ce moment là si on ouvre ses
frontières et bien il faudrait qu'il y
ait réciprocité
or bien souvent il n'ya pas réciprocité
l'essayer d'entre eux d'acheter une
entreprise chinoise essayé d'acheter une
entreprise américaine
je peux vous dire que c'est du boulot et
que on vous empêche bien souvent de le
faire donc il n'y a aucune raison que
les pays ne se protège pas merci
beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
en attendant pour voir ou revoir nos
précédentes émissions rendez vous sur
notre site internet à l'adresse rt
france pointe est réduite
on se quitte avec le mot de la fin
olivier bon écoutez chaque génération vu
l'émission combien de faire chaque
génération a l'impression qu'ils ont
inventé la poudre
malheureusement c'est pas souvent vrai